during a campaign event at a Florida
pumpkin patch I'm not making this up
sure he's at a pumpkin patch Donald
Trump met with pumpkin farmers that's
true yeah there was an awkward moment
when one of the pumpkin farmers tried to
carve Trump's head for a second who's
Justin Erin I don't like Zach it's
perfect over the weekend in Gettysburg
in Gettysburg Donald Trump told a crowd
that as soon as the election ends he
will sue the women accusing him of
sexual misconduct yes it's being called
the second greatest gettysburg address
in history sadly people don't know
Lincoln spent the first two minutes
talking about the women rights ooh yeah
yeah about haters yeah yeah four score
and seven years ago now wait a minute
these chicks out there Lincoln said
chicks that's a known fact this is crazy
story a porn actress a porn actress he's
accusing Donald Trump of making unwanted
sexual advances the porn actress said I
haven't been that mistreated since 20
minutes ago
[Applause]
that's the joke Lincoln ended on at
Gettysburg in a speech today senator
Elizabeth Warren addressed Donald
Trump's recent remarks about hillary
clinton by saying we nasty women are
going to march our nasty feet to cast
our nasty votes yeah i don't know about
you but i'm kind of turned on repress
catholic and nasty feet and nasty women
and i got all crazy yeah too much hay on
friday you know about this a cyber
attack shut down amazon CNN and twitter
yeah apparently the cyber terrorists
shut down amazon first then amazon
suggested they may also like CNN
[Applause]
[Music]
and ready one two cut that one hey it's
true look he's wearing a sweatshirt from
Tron ladies and gentlemen give it up
yeah it's true it's true last Friday
Amazon CNN and Twitter were all down all
over the United States it's a chilling
day that will one day be known in
history as productive Friday actually
got some [ __ ] done how did you hear
about this I got to mention this I love
bikes there's a new end technology
there's a new bike lock that prevents
theft by releasing a gas that makes a
robber throw up if they cut the law yeah
so the good news is your bike wasn't
stolen the bad news it's covered in
robber vomit just cover
[Applause]
I enjoyed acting that outlet I spent
seven hours with the best minds in the
world and you have a mirror working that
out
you